the force of um absolute aristocracy by
the senate the senate was supposed to be
right aristocratic and it was for a
while before like the 15th whatever and
whatever the gas amendment the direction
of direct election of senators and um
the um
and then the presidency was the focus of
monarchy right and this the supreme
court was originally supposed to just be
like digital organ but again that's
another structure of oligarchy and
that's a very very low frequency
oligarchy right which has very slow
turnover
right and then the like power dynamic
between all of these institutions is
left entirely unspecified this is how
basically in a way sort of hamiltonian
government is like killed with marbury
versus madison which you probably read
about in public school where the supreme
court is like no actually i read the
constitution and it doesn't say this but
they meant we're in charge right you
know and so
what's neat about this system and what
has made it like survive a lot of crises
that really probably should have killed
it
is that
basically about every 75 or 80 years
you have a regime change in the united
states you have a replacement of like
the whole actual structural forces of
government
under the same name which is a very
common thing in history um
and at least
go into this more and it leads to like a
different structure of forces so basic
and and it centers around a president
who is actually a monarch
not in that they call themselves king as
you know the roman emperor has never
called them valerian didn't call it ftr
is an example fdr is an example and who
else
lincoln lincoln there you go so
basically what you have in all three
cases is you have basically this startup
regime
and the startup regime in lincoln's case
one of the interesting things about
things about lincoln from a silicon
valley i'm just going to start saying
silicon valley you know sounds better it
sounds better right you know and it has
all these like salacious overtones yes
you know and um you know one of these
silicone valley things is that you look
at the lincoln administration and you
notice that the lincoln administration
is run by this like weirdo self-educated
wild genius political talent abraham
lincoln really the first great american
politician um
and some might say jackson some might
say van buren like lincoln is like a
combination of jackson and van buren
right you know and he's like a
machiavellian genius and he's also like
a genius orator and he really convinces
people to this day like think that
lincoln had like some kind of like
philosophy lincoln's philosophy was
whatever is good for abraham lincoln and
um you know and he was a master
politician and basically um fdr's
philosophy is also whatever is good for
fdr i think
i want to think washington and hamilton
are like pure um but the thing is even
with this level of like you know i don't
really approve of lincoln and fdr i
don't approve of a lot of things that
went on in their regimes
um however
one notices a couple of things about
them one is that basically if you look
for example at the lincoln
administration you'll see that a lot of
it the government the linking controls
mainly focusing on the war effort is
controlled by these young 20-something
guys uh nicole and haye hey later
becomes the secretary of state and like
the mckinley administration and you're
just like aha i see an organization run
absolutely from the top down by a pair
of guys in their 20s right where have i
[ __ ] seen this before right facebook
where have i [ __ ] seen this before
yeah and they win right you know
and um they win because they're awesome
and then you basically see that these
regimes are created as this these
monarchical structures then kind of
central power kind of decays and they
become oligarchies and it's like once
there were like wires going up to the
wheelhouse and the wires are cut why
does central power dictate central bauer
decays because
everything you know it's like that's
asking why do people die people all die
for a different reason they die in
different ways let's get forward to the
fdr regime so the fdr regime is this
quintessence of this like university
driven revolution because they were
there for universities 400 years ago for
the [ __ ] for the [ __ ] upper class
they're from you know for the like of
500 families like the people that
actually matter in this country like and
um
the you know this is a revolution of the
university class fdr himself personally
like lincoln i guess is not really a
manager fdr is actually in some ways a
lot like trump he's a very vain person
he's quite intelligent he's like not
really into books he's like totally
dominates a rome when he comes into it
he's like the most charming person in
the world very shallow but there's a
huge difference between fdr and trump
was which is that fdr is from a super
like one of the most aristocratic
american families
the roosevelts has huge confidence and
he knows how to delegate because every
time trump tries to delegate he's like
can i trust this person right what if
he's trying to become bigger than me you
know what if steve bannon is trying to
exceed me and like right he's like the
worst [ __ ] you know anyway i don't
say i want to say i hate being saying
bad things about people even if they're
donald trump right um you know i think
donald trump would make an excellent
chairman of the board and that is the
right job for him he should be promoted
it's a promotion it's a more important
job being chairman of the board than
being ceo and so donald if you're
listening you know stay off of orbit but
um also
oh he's going on earth
he's on his way to urban stay off of
orbit and start thinking of yourself as
like the like ceo emeritus and you've
made it so anyway so getting back to fdr
and like this is sort of the birth of
what we call the deep state right
originally a turkish word i think first
popular i was by my friend steve saylor
and um peter dale scott had deep
politics maybe yeah yeah yeah it's close
it's the same basic thing yeah right you
know you know scott was very familiar
with like the sort of you know foreign
you know like the eight industrial
complex
you know which my father worked for you
know and the whole foreign policy
insanity
yeah the whole apparatus you know that's
just one arm of this deep state that was
created by trusting the experts right
you know nobody even knows what it's
[ __ ] for anymore right right nobody
even knows what it's [ __ ] for and um
people just like make up reasons like we
got to predict all the viruses right you
know that is the level of like top level
geostrategic
thinking in u.s foreign policy is at the
level of let's collect all the viruses
right um you know but going back to sort
of the the you know the birth of this
system like
there's a couple of things that i say to
describe like the new deal
and the new deal era um one is i was
particularly struck by
a book in theodore white's making the
president in 1960 very famous political
book in which he's talking to one of the
kennedy people or one of the older
people who's kind of involved in like
the new frontier and we when we think
about the new frontier we think about
the kennedy world and there's this kind
of edge of monarchy to like kennedy
world because this is a big family and
right you know roosevelt had kids as
well but they were just like incredibly
corrupt incompetent [ __ ] there was no
way to take them seriously as
politicians you know unlike say teddy
kennedy right maybe it was more serious
time as well but the thing is you see
all of these monarchical complex
complexes developing
right and so you see that when you have
someone like fdr who i encourage like
all of my fans but especially the libs
to think of when they think of as
monarchy when you see someone like fdr
basically
like you know and you see that okay he's
not technically a hereditary monarch but
like the sort of attributes of
hereditary monarchy that are like
hereditary succession start forming as
they have formed for thousands of years
throughout human history so like you
know you start to from this perspective
you start to lose your kind of temporal
exceptionalism you're like history isn't
ending at all and like government is
kind of the same thing it's always been
right right and and you know if
government is the same thing it's always
been it's easy to look at fdr's world
and see a couple of different things one
is remember i was talking there was a
guy like
t h white um t e white something will i
forget his name um author of making the
president making the president 1960 is
um
um yes yes
he's talking to someone who remembers
the new deal era
and um
he's um
basically in the new frontier act and
when we think of like the new frontier
in camelot this is like the most
exciting time ever this is like my god
like being a frontiersman like yes you
know
like you know kennedy has robert frost
read it his inauguration biden has
amanda gorman right one of these things
maybe not quite like the other right you
know like and so you have this like you
know excellence right
at the at the top and the sense of like
heredity sort of forming
and you're just like what is this how
what does this like kennedy cult of the
kennedys have to do with like
the american revolution right you know
and um and so you're seeing all these
things develop those things are way more
intense in the roosevelt era this guy
who remembers the new deal is like oh
yeah you know everything seems kind of
dull and drab in the new frontier to
anyone who remembers the new deal that's
how like how much [ __ ] startup energy
the new you had it's like working at
google in 2003 right basically you know
here is you know let's say you graduate
from harvard in like
1936
versus 2016. if you graduate from
harvard in 1936 with a degree in this
new field of economics a field that has
basically been completely reinvented in
the last 20 years um you're like oh you
know i'm a harvard man i'm really smart
and i know somebody who knows somebody
who knows tommy corcoran
or felix frankfurter or someone like
that and somebody calls somebody and i
get a phone call and they're like would
you like to come to dc yeah
yeah you know concealing your excitement
you're like sure okay i'm not doing
anything else this time of year and you
come to and but what would i be doing
and um you know the voice on the phone
is like we don't know and it doesn't
matter come to dc right and you come to
dc and somebody puts you in an office
and is like okay
your job is to go here's five million
dollars your job is to go electrify
arkansas like you know that's the medial
experience that's a [ __ ] startup
experience and you're like 21 right and
you're like okay and you get it [ __ ]
done in like nine months yeah right and
and like that is what created the
enormous faith in like the powers of the
us government that people had at that
time it actually the new deal actually
got [ __ ] done and um
ever driven on route one yeah project of
course imagine that happening now
imagine you know right it is the laugh
right you know and so it's this
amazingly effective thing it's full of
the best people in society um and it's
like incredibly dynamic it gives you
incredible levels of like personal
responsibility at incredibly young ages
now imagine you graduate from harvard in
2016 with a degree in economics you're
like okay i'm going to apply for an
unpaid internship on the hill do they
buy their interns i don't know
uh in any case you really should have
family that can help you out because you
got to spend thirteen hundred dollars
right on a room the size of a shoebox
and then you're on somebody's staff
you're answering letters from pork pie
iowa yeah and then you know like did
they ever write that you know even when
you after 20 years you're not even
writing legislation certainly the
senators like the you know the
congressmen never write any legislation
they barely look at it they pass these
bills they haven't even read the staff
doesn't even write the legislation they
get they collect they edit the
legislation they get lines from like
lobbyists and activists which are the
kind of two real sides of congress right
and you're just like this is like this
insane
thing and like as a young person there's
just no like joy in it so as a young
person your mind naturally turns after
75 or 80 years and by the way let me
finish explaining what happens at the
top so fdr is a not a brilliant manager
he's a brilliant collector of talents
he's like more like peter thiel than
elon musk right and so he basically
correct collects his entire talents at
the head of these or this organization
um and does all these like completely
unethical things about world war ii i
always recommend nicholson baker's book
human smoke um it's sort of one of the
few
it sort of gives you the right mood of
world war ii which is not a marvel movie
um and um that's you know as much as i
want it is not a marvel movie right you
know and and and so
fdr in 44
realizes that he's dying anyone who's in
the node knows he's dying remember the
[ __ ] people out there are so
brainwashed by the cathedral of that
time they don't even know he's paralyzed
he's had like a private subway station
in new york right like you know it's
like this is a level at which like if
you look at the distance at the level
how easy it is to like contain the truth
from the perspective of the media yeah
at that time it's just like this amazing
right you know it's amazing right you
know it's orwellian like orwell worked
for the bbc right he knew this right you
know and so or um roosevelt in 44
he's dying he knows he's dying
everybody's in the no-nos he's dying the
public is informed that he's in the best
of health fit as a fiddle right and
anyone who looks at him can see he's
dying and so his previous um you know
vice president has been henry wallace
now one thing to understand about the
30s which was sometimes called the red
decade is that in the 30s everyone who
was cool was a communist yeah right okay
um just read a book by eugene lyons
called the red decade and you'll see
that clearly communist or a communist
sympathizer my grandparents were
actually communists this is a
non-debatable historical fact right so
uh you know but basically the communists
are at this time they're selling like
one or two percent of the population if
you look at the people who voted for the
same guy henry wallace in 48 when he ran
on the progressive party ticket note
that word progressive yeah that's also
what my grandparents called themselves
in fact they were card-carrying
communists right um you've heard that
word somewhere else progressive right um
and its meaning has never changed it's
just like most people who call
themselves progressives don't even know
the history of the word right they're
like those people in like new mexico who
still practice like the jewish rituals
you know but don't even know the jews
you know um and um but that's where you
know the like even cancellation that's a
that's a communist practice that comes
from an internal like like internal
if you read a book called the romance of
american communism there are all these
like cancellation memoirs from like the
50s right from inside the party um and
so anyway but fdr realizes that
he intends to found a regime he intends
to found
something that is his that will last for
many years
certainly into the 2020s
after him
and therefore
america must no longer be a monarchy
what must happen is that basically all
of these bright amazing people like the
best and the brightest right you know in
the 60s it's still kind of the best and
the brightest you can use that without
like joking like nobody nobody would
describe like susan rice is the best and
the brightest right you know and um
she's not dumb right um um you know
actually her son is like a famous based
stanford person yeah um susan rice is
not dumb uh this is public um and susan
rice is not dumb um for sure she's not
dumb she's not dumb but she's not
[ __ ] um dean atchison correct john
bolton is also not d natchez you know i
read [ __ ] john bolton's book and he's
like basically he's like i am the second
coming of dean atchison yeah he's like
you have the same muscles
yeah okay
avoided wars yeah well you know exactly
i can say some things
know but about the united
bolton loves uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
in any case basically like these are
pygmies right you know and and so you
know what you see is basically fdr does
this pharyonic thing
where as a successor and vice president
in 1944
he picks harry truman
and who the [ __ ] is harry truman
harry truman is a nobody
so what and like he's a nobody of like
very limited intelligence very limited
he's not really prominent he's a member
of like the pendergast boss faction he's
not even a progressive democrat he's not
even a new dealer right and so basically
by by picking someone who's not even a
new dealer which is a master stroke it
was fdr's finest stroke because he's
basically saying who is going to succeed
me the answer is a nobody right and it's
immediately reminiscent of alexander the
great when he was dying i don't know if
this story is true story i've read it's
cool story he's dying and all of his
like henchmen he's like 30 or something
all of his henchmen are gathered around
him and they're like who shall inherit
the empire of alexander who shall be the
next you know who shall the kingdom go
to who should the empire go to and his
last two words are tokratos
which means to the strongest
ah
and so you know almost these these
people almost like figurative like like
pull out their [ __ ] surroundings and
like the funeral right right you know
and so
but fdr is doing something slightly
different by saying power should go
to nobody he ensures that
harry truman does not have the gravitas
or power to actually command the deep
state that's right and so he basically
lets the deep state command him and give
him little teleprompter scripts to read
he's not like demented and he doesn't
start reading the directions on the
teleprompter but he basically is like
inaugurates the era of the kind of
semi-figurehead president president and
power has a vat you know since he didn't
have
anything
to eisenhower eisenhower's openly saying
yeah i don't really know what goes i
don't really know what goes on right and
since then nixon does this thing nixon
does this thing where he's like no i
will really be the president and try to
regain command of the bureaucracy good
luck this is the way bolton and barr
also think right bolton and barr also
have this thing of like let's actually
try to where are the grown-ups in the
room we will actually make the us
government work no you won't you [ __ ]
you know and like go like shave your
mustache and retire right you know and
and so um that basically sort of brings
us to the like political structure of
today that's how we got to the oligarchy
we're in today if you pull back from
that story of like where the deep state
is the new deal
it's the personal regime
of fdr without and then the new deal fdr
the new deal comes into play all of the
people the architects of the new deal
become the heads of all these
institutions
all of these institutions are now
more powerful than harry truman great
foundation right the great foundation
you know like carnegie rockefeller ford
there's a whole philanthropic industrial
and all of these and they all have
exactly the same [ __ ] ideas and these
ideas are like dumber than a post and
smell like [ __ ] does this
does this structure work at all does it
work at all no it has to be completely
ripped out yeah and here is basically
the problem is that it has to be
completely ripped out and the only sort
of form of government that can rip it
out is the same form of government that
the u.s goes through every 75 or 80
years which is a monomial
which is basically and so is the worry
because a lot of people that say that
read your work and say it's very
interesting but they go the people that
really also
seem to like it are people that
love or seem to flirt with the idea of
theocracy so so yeah so you know
it's funny you should use the word
theocracy right tim you know because
have you ever seen signs on people's
lawns that tell you what to think
no no for sure like and that's another
kind of theory and so yeah so so so in a
way it's like it's an interesting point
because in a sense like
you conclude when looking at history
that sort of the libertarian kind of
freedom of speech world
has never exactly been a thing right and
so your question of how to sort of do
something like that is like basically
what you have to realize is that most
human beings will sort of always believe
what they're taught to think